You now know that chronic diseases drive most U.S. health care costs.
Once diagnosed, they're usually not curable.
What patients do in terms of behavior and compliance with
their treatments is critical to success in managing them.
As a result, there has long been interest in the potential of technology in
the home to create a more continuous and coordinated approach to care of these patients.
This is yet another old health informatics idea,
only now coming to fruition.
Here's a photo of Steve Kaufmann,
one of the early innovators in this space,
with Hank, his home assisted nursing care robot.
Hank offered a wide variety of voice control nursing services
to patients at home in the mid 1990's.
Among other things, Hank dispensed medications at
the proper time and took physiologic measurements,
such as blood pressure with its patient-operated devices,
using the technology of the day.
During the same period,
I was one of the founders of a company that provided
an electronic records system for
the home care nurses who took care of patients after they left the hospital.
We could see the benefit of knowing more about the patients between
nursing visits and reinforcing the instructions the nurses provided.
We developed this roughly cigar-box-sized touchscreen device that,
like Hank, spoke to the patients.
It, too, had integrated physiologic measurement devices.
Of course, as you'd expect,
software for home care is now available on smartphones.
This example is from AlayaCare, a Canadian company.
It provides nurses with a patient overview at a glance on their phone,
along with important documentation,
administrative, and billing functions.
Patients record some of the data as is illustrated here.
This example question would be part of something similar to
a Likert survey that collects the patient's point of view on a daily basis.
Along with vital signs data coming from the peripherals,
it informs an algorithm we'll discuss later.
Of course, it is no longer necessary to provide
integrated physiologic devices since they are
consumer-level products and most have wireless Bluetooth syncing capability.
The company says, it can sync data from over 200 devices.
It brings this data together,
as shown here, for quick review by the nurse.
Finally, this dashboard provides nurses with a quick overview of their patients.
It provides a graphical representation of the incoming data from various devices.
Importantly, since a value might be normal for one patient but abnormal for another,
each measure has patient-specific upper and lower bound thresholds
that trigger workflows for various care team members.
If a threshold boundary is detected,
a risk score is calculated using rules developed by machine learning.
The risk score is a combination of the patients ICD-10 diagnoses,
demographic information, vital signs data,
and their Likert survey.
AlayaCare train their model using data sets from their remote monitoring partners
that critically include events such as hospital re-admissions or E.R. visits.